doch mal eine frage der antinori so zwar
steht der mir auch projekte oder auf
blonde und welche voraussetzungen muss
eine frau erfüllen um anfang aufzubieten
jetzt über grüße an die hbb brüder und
diese gerne wieder oder blondine ist
eigentlich nicht so wichtig bei mir aber
ich also von mir ist ausgesetzt sind
also ich meine vor der bisher zum
beispiel projekte oder hat braune haare
und deswegen also ist eigentlich egal
kommt drauf an dass kontrollwahn so kann
ich dazu nicht sagen
ex-miss annika fragt wer von euch beiden
ist auf die idee gekommen youtube videos
zu machen kann man so nicht sagen also
wissen wo du dann weiter auf die idee
gekommen
und das hat sich halt so ergeben ich
weiß ich weiß gar nicht mehr eigentlich
für beide oberwald möchte wissen lasst
ihr euch von tätern runterziehen
also ich glaube - die wirklich von
helfern runterziehen lassen
allein was älter sind oder älter habe
eigentlich keine beschäftigung aus
woraus ein zu helfen und ich glaube auch
so wenn man halt die ganze fenster sieht
dann gibt es da nicht schon ausgleich
und dann gibt dann motivation die ganzen
hätte einfach zu ignorieren ist lena hat
folgende frage was sagen ihre
klassenkameraden oder lehrer zu euch
dass ihr videos macht also die
klassenkameraden freunde zu wissen sie
dass schon die kenntnis schon seit
jahren und die an sich daran gewöhnt
also für diesen sätzen ist besonderes
mehr
und die lehrer die sprechen also bald
einige lehrer wissen das und sprechen
einen dann ab und super irgendwie drauf
an
mein mathelehrer zum beispiel nennt wir
doch da nehme ich immer noch aber
ansonsten die kennt deshalb schon und
für diese setzt ist besonderes mehr weil
die halt schon die die wissen natur
besteht also für die bin ich irgendwie
romantisch sondern ein roman roman also
christoph garten
wir sind besser und haben ein paar
fragen reich erstens welches mikrofon
verwendet ihr und zweitens wie seit das
so schnell bekannt geworden
wir machen auch parodien
bis zum nächsten mal hey wir haben also
wir haben mikrofon also kamera mikrofon
haben wir in rodde video mike für euro
der sohn und studium mikrofon für die
parodien zum aufnehmen
auch von rothe nt 12 oder so heißt es
ich weiß ganz genau kann zeigt google
das ist ein ziemlich gutes studium
mikrofon mit dem kann man echt gute
aufnahmen machen und davor hatten wir 1
von fresenius die meisten sagt also die
meisten sagt gesetzt ist an die die sich
damit auskennen sagt das was und zur
zweiten frage was wir die zweite frage
was war die zweite frage wie
wahrscheinlich nur zweite frage die so
schnell erfolgreich geworden sind also
ich glaube allgemein auf youtube ist es
wichtig wenn man erfolgreich sein will
dass man abgesehen vom inhalt und von
spaß auch noch durchhaltevermögen hat
also wenn man es wichtig dass man sich
irgendwie nach einem monat aufhört mit
youtube nur weil man nicht nach dem
ersten video keine fünf millionen klicks
hat also wichtig ist an das
durchhaltevermögen und wenn man dann
auch gute videos langfristig produziert
und raus haut und es den leuten gefällt
dann hat man irgendwann auch erfolg und
ja also man soll nicht sofort aufgeben
nacht weiter habt spaß
folgende frage kommen von hayabusa wer
ist euer lieblings youtuber mein
lieblings youtuber ist bad berka ist ein
anderer name also ein youtube macht auch
parodien stern tv den weil die einfach
nicht nur aufwendig und extrem blutprobe
produziert sondern auch meinem humor so
entsprechend vielleicht kennt in der ein
oder andere ich glaube ein roman ist
genauso also von irgendwie auf die
deutschen habe ich jetzt keinen
speziellen lieblings youtuber und anna
was ist euer größter traum
unser größter traum oder mein größter
traum ist es auf jeden fall mein größter
traum ist auf jeden fall einfach das zu
machen was mir spaß macht und am besten
davon zu leben also eigentlich youtube
ist eigentlich ein traum so der sendung
wurde ihrem leben schon mein traum und
wird jetzt auch die schule weg gehen
würde dann wäre es perfekt und mein
traum ist heute in erfüllung gegangen wo
wir mit clixoom ein interview führen
konnten
hallo fist of und die loches ja also ich
hätte damals zwei fragen erste frage wer
ist euer lieblings rapper und warum
und die zweite frage wie bleibt ihre
zukunft zu gestalten wollt ihr weiterhin
youtube videos machen und oder wollt ihr
bestimmte jobs anfang oder ausbildung
und wenn ja welche ok danke im voraus
und tschüss ich habe erstmal respekt an
die kohle maske an die frage also
lieblingsrapper ist bei mir jetzt als
rebell metrix und farid bang
also bei mir ist beides lieblingsrapper
ja also von über metrix auf jeden fall
mit dem sandy auch so ganz gut und casey
level der macht auch gute musik finde
ich und genau was man was wir auch die
zweite frage was wir für die zukunft
geplant haben
wie schon gesagt habe ich schon einen
tag gesagt auf jeden fall weiter wir
wollen auf jeden fall weiter erst
youtube machen und auch was mit medien
also produzieren
und wir haben jetzt nicht wie vor im
bann nur noch ins venn sie zu gehen also
das ist ganz unser ziel wir wollen
erstmal wirklich weiter mit youtube
machen uns macht das spaß und wir wollen
werden noch weitere singles raus hauen
wir werden einfach weitermachen und
gucken wie sich das alles entwickelt